في الاثناء قالت وكاله هاور القريبه من
حزب العمال الكردستاني ان الجيش التركي
يواصلوا قصفه العنيف بالطائرات الحربيه
والمسيره والاسلحه الثقيله على مختلف
مناطق شمالي وشرقي سوريا وذكرت الوكاله
وان القصف الساده فمطار منك في ريف حلب
وقريه عين دقنه في منطقه الشهباء وقريه
مرعناز في عفرين بينما ذكر المركز
الاعلامي لما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه ان القوات التركيه
بالقبائث والهاون والدبابات على الفرات
وكباني عين العرب وقت الابيض باكثر من 400
قضيته هاون ودبابه
الى شبكه مراسلين من ريف حلب الشمالي ادهم
ابو الحسين ومن الحدود التركيه السوريه
عمر الحاج ادهم ابدا معك اطلعنا على نتائج
القصف حتى الان
جلال حقيقه هو اليوم الثامن من بدا
العمليات العسكريه التركيه التي تستهدف
بها تركيا وزاره الدفاع تركيا لما تعرف في
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه ولكن اللافت اليوم
هذه الليله هو قصف مطار من العسكري شمال
حلب وهو مطار وموقع عسكري ومشترك ما بين
قوات النظام السوري وايضا قوات همم ما
تعرف قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه هذا تطور
ربما له ابعاد اا كبيره وربما همم بحسب
عسكريين يرسل دلالات واشارات على اصرار
همم وزاره الدفاع تركيا وقوه التركيه على
العمليه البريه التي ربما تكون والشيكه
بحسب قياده في قوات المعارضه بحسب همم همم
الاوضاع الميدانيه هناك رفع للجازيه من
قبل فصائل القوات المعارضه اضافه الى
تحركات للجيش التركي والقواعد التركيه اذا
اردنا ان نتحدث عن القصف التركي الذي يطال
همم مواقع كبيره وعشرات النقاط في ريف حلب
الشمالي ابتداء من ريف حلب الشمالي انه
يتحدث عن منطقه عفرين والمنطقه الجنوبيه
منها محيط رفعت همم اضافه الى منطقه همم
عين العرب القصف المدفعي يتركز بشكل كثير
على همم ناحيه عين العرب هناك عشرات
المواقع التي استدفتها المدفعيه همم
التركيه وما زالت تستهدفها بشكل مستمر
طيله الايام همم الماضيه لاحظنا خلال
الليله الماضيه ايضا هناك قصف بمسيرات
تركيه لعده مواقع في المنطقه الشرقيه من
نهر الفرات تحديدا من طاقه همم تمر وايضا
همم راس العين كان هناك استهداف همم
لطائرات همم مسيره استهدفت عربات وايضا
استهدفت ارتال لما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه لتشكل وحدات حمايه الشعب
الكرديه عمودها الفقري الى همم هذا الجانب
من همم من هذه المعلومات هناك ايضا حشودات
قوات النظام السوري باتجاه المنطقه الفرقه
25 اضافه الى حرس الجمهوري والفرقه
الرابعه كل هذه المؤشرات على الارض تدل
ربما على انه سيكون هناك عمليه عسكريه نعم
جلال عمر بن المفهوم التركي هل تشهد
العمليه تطورا
نعم جلال لابد بدايه من الاشاره الى هذه
الزيارات المفاجئه حقيقه التي قام بها
وزير الدفاع خصوصي اكار اضافه الى قائد
الاركان يشار جولار الى مجموعه من النقاط
امس كان خلوصي عكار في قياده القوات
البريه للجيش التركي في منطقه في ولايه
خطا كان برفقته كما ذكرت قائد الاركان
اضافه الى قاده كل الاسلحه البريه
والبحريه والجويه التركيه ثم بعد ذلك
انتقل خلوصي افكار الى الشرق اليوم الى
ولايه هكاري وايضا الى نقاط الجيش التركي
هناك حاله من رفع الجاهزيه في القوات
التركيه وان كنا لم نشهد استخدامها عزتنا
عسكريه من مناطق مختلفه ذلك لان القوات
التركيه على مدار الخمس او سته سنوات سته
سنوات الماضيه استدعت كثيرا من قواتها
وكان هناك تغيير في اا تموقع في موضع يعني
الجيش التركي بالنسبه
على الحدود بالفعل هناك استمرار الاستهداف
التركي على همم كثير من المناطق من بينها
كما ذكر الزميل ادهم هناك في عين العرب
ومناطق اخرى داخل سوريا وتقول تركيا انها
دائما ما تستهدف نقاط الارهابيين اضافه
الى هناك من مصادر محليه هناك كان هناك
بعض ال- ال- النيران التي سماها جانب
التركي بانها النيران استفزازيه وقعت على
مناطق في سروج وايضا في مناطق اخرى قادمه
من الجانب السوري حتى الان ليس هناك افصاح
جلال عن العمليه العسكريه يعني القوات
التركيه او الرئيس اكثر من فتره يقول ان
الجيش التركي
اي عمليه عسكريه في اي وقت العشاء وفي
الظروف التي يشاؤها الجيش التركي حتى انه
تحدث في وقت سابق عن مجموعه اهداف
المحتمله همم
سنضرب الارهابيين شكرا
مهمه بالنسبه لجانب التركي تبعد وجود هذه
الوحدات عن الحدود السوريه
وادهم ابو الحسين في ريف حلب الشمالي